el conflicto armado resurge en colombia
es la conclusión que se extrae del
informe de retos humanitarios 2022 del
comité internacional de la cruz roja
lorenzo kharafi jefe de la delegación en
el país hizo el siguiente balance el año
pasado la situación humanitaria en
colombia empeoró eso fue debido al
recrudecimiento en 2021 de los seis
conflictos armados no internacionales
que afectan el país el ccr en hombre los
conflictos vigentes y destacó a sus
actores el estado el ejército de
liberación nacional las autodefensas
gaitanistas de colombia y las distintas
facciones de las disidencias de la
extinta guerrilla de las farc estos
combates están generando distintas
problemáticas la afectación por
artefactos explosivos el desplazamiento
masivo y el confinamiento forzado
alcanzaron los niveles más altos en los
últimos cinco años el conflicto afecta
principalmente a 17 de los 32
departamentos y en 2021 se registraron
800 84 violaciones al derecho
internacional humanitario
colombia está a las puertas de sus
elecciones presidenciales y lorenzo
kharafi quiso hacer un llamado a los
candidatos y al final del 2022 podríamos
tener una situación aún más compleja de
la que tuvimos en 2021 por esta razón
hacemos un llamado a los que resultaran
elegidos en las contiendas electorales
para que coloquen al centro de su acción
y priorice en la asistencia la
protección a las personas y las
comunidades afectadas por los conflictos
armados y la violencia
colombia vivió un proceso de paz en 2016
entre la guerrilla de las farc y el
estado fue la desmovilización de la
mayor guerrilla de américa latina y
aunque la violencia de un respiro el ccr
avisa del recrudecimiento y la ocupación
de grupos armados de los espacios donde
desaparecieron las farc